1378 kilometer australien mit singapore
airlines täglich im airbus a380 ab
zürich
[Musik]
wir sind sehr fest bei mount barnett
rothaus und das ist die hand kommt ja
die unzählige einzelteile sind im alter
brand schock sie zum glück hat er
hilfsbereit calling kommen jetzt wieder
dran machen ja dann können wir weiter
bis nach schweden schweiz entschuldigung
schweiz und du bist automechaniker nein
ich bin der manager des rathauses
aber wenn du hier draußen arbeitest
musst du alles drauf haben
ich kann von allem ein wenig und nichts
ich habe ein kleines dankeschön für mich
ein schweizer taschenmesser schön
nochmals vielen dank und vergesst euer
sowie die nicht
[Musik]
ja ja
durch den von roten kontinent
[Musik]
nach drei stunden
für miki er über das plötzliche sie noch
diese noch locker
[Musik]
wenn sie mal das war gewollt schlagen
einfach nicht zahlen
die hotel reservation krise noch immer
gehört und das ist pure luxus
[Musik]
nach sollte vollmondnacht wärmend erste
sonnenstrahl adventure einer schlucht in
millionen von jahren durch das ehemalige
rolf presse
[Musik]
wascht werden
die endlose vitrine vom kontinent sind
heute praktisch mancher leveraging es
auf der suche nach nahrung durchs land
zog
[Musik]
vor 220 jahren
so
das privatgrundstück
richtig ärgerlich
ich habe mit dem level paulina ob
gemacht hat mit ihrer familie im
kalkarer camp herzoperation vor den
china zusammen mit dem willicher
australier vor der ureinwohner keine
lehrer aber ihnen natur und mit der
natur
hallo josip colina sein
ja das bin ich bin es wäre schön dich
kennenzulernen fantastischem wetter sehr
schön und angenehm kühl seit zwei wochen
wer bist du
ich bin zwar nicht die nächsten zwei
tage zusammen mit der familie vom netz
also alles wasser dass du hier im
camping ist kannst du ohne bedenken
klinken nun schleunigst lass dir einfach
in ruhe die kommen nicht um dich zu
beißen die haben besseres zu tun
du hast sie einfach vorbei ziehen und es
gibt keine probleme kennt hier um das du
nicht das ist meine einzige regel hier
wir leben in einer symbiotischen
beziehung mit der natur dingos kommen
vorbei meldete
neulich steckt ein strauß und klopfens
autorin
das ist also die toll aus die haben wir
für unsere gäste aufgestellt
wenn du auf diesem bett schläft fühlst
du dich wie das ist wenn man kennt musst
du dich wie ein familienmitglied fühlen
mit diesem respekt behandeln wir uns
hier treffen die nächsten tage gehöre
ich zu deiner familie
du bist mein bruder großartig bis später
[Musik]
gestorben vor den medien in your room
kraft als sie zuvor jeden traditionelle
londoner kontrahenten neville zum hirte
vor ihrem stammes landberg holen
mit der enorme verschiedenen camp
finanziert aber unterhalt vor dem land
es ist eine große ehre für meine familie
die hüter dieses landes zu sein ich
zeige dir heute wie glücklich sind
ich sehe es dir an
hier musste einfach glücklich aufwachen
am morgen wenn nicht bist du tot erlebst
du himmel das holz dass meine tochter
angelina trägt ist von großer
spiritueller bedeutung für uns wäre ich
an dich heute wirklich auf unserem land
willkommen
wir holen dich in den schützenden rauch
damit dem nichts passiert und braucht
wird alle schlechten geister verträgen
die auf mein land bringt die werden hier
im feuer gleich danach werden wir einen
fantastischen tag haben
denkst du mein herz
google
wir verwenden das holz von drei
unterschiedlichen bäumen eukalyptus
grabosch und papieren dieser rauch
reinigt uns unternimmt alles böse von
uns nicht wirklich gut wunderbar jetzt
muss ich das feuer ersticken
damit wir den rauch riechen einrücken du
wartest hier mit den kindern macht ihr
das häufig zuoberst aufs feuer legen wir
als caritas bild wir machen sie mussten
wir das mir auch gibt und wie mein papa
gesagt hat dass nicht alle schlechte von
uns weg alles schlechte dass du
mitbringst und das schlechte das auf
unserem land ist es ist wie eine
zeremonie in der kirche
der lappen das vorhaben bei kinder frei
denkst du gemessen an ich werde dir
einen honig band zeigen
angelina fährt mit seinen versteckten 8
mit wild bieten wir stecken ein ast ins
loch und stochern rum
das ist nicht kosten ich probiere es
noch mal lecker honigwabe das loch haben
wir schon vor einiger zeit geburt warum
hat es so viel honig ist das eine biene
nein das ist eine honig ameise nein das
hier ja das ist eine biene kannst du
aber nicht essen dann will ich auch weiß
ich bin süchtig danach wie papa mit
seiner schokolade
du hast lieber honig als schokolade
[Musik]
wir verbringen den nachmittag an laut
große war traditionell wieder ein genie
hinter gitter
angelina unter simon kennen alle
pflanzen und tieren ergangen
[Musik]
simonet verschiedenen fort erklärt wie
man baramundi fischt hinter ich ständig
burger leben kannst du mir helfen ja wie
muss ich die route bewegen wenn du den
kölner ein höchst machst du immer
ruckartig 123 mit kleinen pausen
dazwischen dann sieht es aus wie ein
verwundeter fisch der nicht mehr richtig
schwimmen können
das lockt in bayern nun die 1 er will
einen einfachen fall
[Applaus]
wenn wir glück haben wirst du uns heute
abend alle satt machen
ich versuche mein bestes wie sich schon
bislang will attend gelingt mir der
erste chance
das netz langsam nicht ausrutschen
sein lauf hier über ok geschafft
der nebel hat in der letzten nacht stark
nachlasse und berechnet wenn das
verbieten darf man also nicht will
auf missfallen blick bilder jetzt haben
wir genug fisch umsatz werden mehr
brauchen wir nicht
bevor wir gehen müssen wir den fluss und
dem land danken für das essen das du
gefangen hast ja jedes mal wenn wir uns
in der natur bedienen sollen wir den
tier dem fisch unseren respekt und
danken dem land das es uns ermöglicht
hat essen nach hause zu bringen
es ist ganz einfach wir nehmen unseren
schweiß aus der achselhöhle und
streichen ihn auf den boden wie eine
unterschrift
[Musik]
das sagen wir danke für das vergnügen
und die baramundi danke dass wir diesen
fluss hinter unserem haus haben wir
versprechen gut nach hinzuschauen
[Musik]
also gehen wir nach hause
das wird ein fest dessen dritte abend
das ist schluss von angelina und dem
simon direkten aber ihrem wohnhaus
sie sind die einzige stelle hier im
busch lud zum rasten und hilft ihr kind
mit der aufgabe lehre sitzt einige
hundert kilometer wieder wackelt übers
internet mit ihrer schieren verbunden
guten morgen angelina wie geht es dir
guten morgen ihr geht es gut meint natur
in china sucht und china apotheke hier
vieles was er verschiedene familie
betrieben
das ist der baum dinge suchen sehr gut
gegen entzündungen und keller ich
befestige dem plastiksack hier in du
kannst ihr helfen die medizin zu können
mit deiner familie bist du mein bruder
du hältst den ast so und ziehst einfach
die blätter vor fahrer von mclaren sieht
über 60 jahre auf dem kontinent mit der
ankunft von der wiese siegers inter
bridges in ihrem eigenen land antrag
wurde
du hast dein schicksal in die hand
genommen und etwas aufgebaut
warum schaffen dass nur so wenige
grätschen
ich frage dich warm machen grundsätzlich
so wenig menschen etwas aus ihrem leben
nicht nur in rieschs
ich denke mal volk muss jetzt rannte
dann verpassten anschluss wir wurden 250
jahre lang kolonialisiert wir müssen
begreifen dass der kontinent nicht mehr
nach uns geht
er gehört in schwarzen und weißen
leider haben wir eine weiße regierung
und wer bridges müssen uns der weisen
anpassen
viele haben alkoholprobleme
sie ziehen in die städte und verlieren
das traditionelle wissen ich denke das
ist doch das hauptproblem
oder wenn deine menschen den stolz in
all den ländern die von den weißen
erobert wurden lebten stolze menschen
wurden zu lange unterdrückt dieses
trauma veränderte das denken der
menschen mit doppelten 250 jahre lang in
den schwindel die uns die regierung zu
geworfen hat jetzt sagen sie hey wir
wollen die besten zurück es hat aber
nicht gemerkt dass wir gar nie gelernt
haben zu schwimmen bevor man den
menschen die schwimmwesten wecken muss
man ihnen das schwimmen sonst trinken
sie
severin ist indes enorm swiss war in der
modernen welt ganz einfach nicht gefragt
ist ist einer von den ganz wenige was es
geschafft hätte
touristen sind bereits zahlen vom vortag
in china traditionell war seine
historische
dj charts anführt zum doktor in statt
geld nur im notfall
diese medizin ist sehr gut für boxer für
den morgen nach dem kampf wenn ihnen
alles wie unsere bush mit ziehen hat
keine nebenwirkungen
du kannst du nicht überdosieren vieles
könntest du sogar essen
die show hat mir lieber rahmen des
kochens und welches ist das beste stück
das filetstück warum für mich meine
kinder und ich essen den kopf und
schwanz
der kopf ist für den ältesten mann am
tisch der schwanz für die älteste frau
darum habe ich mir vorher gesagt sag
nicht überstürzt ich will dieses oder
jenes stoppen denn im lauf seines lebens
wirst du den ganzen fisch essen
gespendet
alles zu seiner zeit und nichts
überstürzen wenn niemand bettelt ich
will die s ich will jenes bekommt er es
erst recht nicht dann gebe ich dir also
den kopf simon willst deinen kopf den
großen oder einen kleinen nimm du den
großen
ich nehme
danke du bist als weiße australierin mit
einem aperitif heirat
wie hast du all diese regeln gelernt das
war ein langsamer prozess lebens familie
hat mich sehr herzlich aufgenommen und
akzeptiert
sie haben nie gesagt so muss das machen
sie gaben mir zeit zu lernen
vor allem in die sie mir dinger zeit
ich mache manchmal etwas schwer von
begriff aber sie waren geduldig und
großzügig uns natürlich konnte mir
helfen zum beispiel bei den
tischmanieren die ungewohnt fahren
wisst ihr noch was wir in der schweiz
sagen vor dem essen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
polina sprung ins modelgeschäft honisch
im traditionsgeschäft im eigenen land in
sotschi vom lucky country in
hohenklingen
im ski rothaus lag in sandwich pause wir
machen durch lautstärke show führen mit
jedem monströse road trains pause 42
das sind jetzt habe ich nur ein
schweizer straße unterwegs sind derzeit
vier mal so viel gewicht wie vor glaube
ist
so
der zement das ist gerade sechs meter
sprint bei lastwagen
wäre so als ungetüm durch west
australien fort verdient rund 160 frauen
gremien und rief auch vom australischen
durchschnittlich kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
toller lastwagen den du dafür hast was
ist die faszination so einen traktor
fahren
es ist ein gutes leben in einer
wunderbaren gegen tirol
gerade bei diesem wetter selbst in der
sommerhitze hat diese landschaft dienen
ich bin zwar auf einem bauernhof
aufgewachsen fahre aber schon mein
ganzes leben lastwagen
du verdienst zwar viel geld aber hier
ist auch alles enger und teuer oder wir
alle müssen vom ihnen boom profitieren
die firmen wollen so viel geld machen
wie möglich
die meisten akzeptieren die hohen kreise
manchmal schimpfen wir über die hohen
lebenskosten
schließlich verdienen wie viel mehr als
anderswo
an der ostküste würde ich für die
gleiche arbeit weniger als die hälfte
verdienen
die lebenskosten hier an der westküste
sind aber nur etwa ein viertel höher als
im osten sagte dein bankkonto das ist
nicht schlecht läuft
studierende die bank rzb doringer
kreisen
[Musik]
650 und 700 ps stark unglaublich
die road trains and mine ihn ergangen
ich mache mich auf den weg zur krise
erzmine australien
[Musik]
die jungen die von eine typische
minenstadt in westaustralien freenet
westküste als rückständig und verschlafe
holte sie den pro jahr erlaubt sie mit
dem abbau von rohstoffen enormen boom
rund 40 arbeitsplätze entstanden
immobilie und ladens kosten sind
explodiert
überall schießen moderne gesichtslose
wohnhauses im boden grad wird es im juni
newman ist es typisches beispiel vor dem
boom der torte stadtmitte im
niemandsland irland rund sagt stegmann
in einer schmiede
das geht mir da die kulisse und das ist
statt jeder zur jungen würde man sagen
dürfen ins prozent von der wohn hier
schaffen vermieden oder verzerrt jenen
die unbenommen durchschnittsalter 30
also wer hier ist der kohle machen nina
wird statt klären zu einem großen teil
dem britisch australische
rohstoffkonzern
mina selber helfen nur im rahmen von
rhetorischen tool film
riesige maschine waren jährlich acht
millionen dollar erzielt der rohstoff
für die stahlindustrie
hauptabnehmer sind china und japan
[Musik]
wir haben manche in der künste verwarnt
du bist nobby der coach ich bin zwar
schön dich zu treffen
ich werde den boxfans klar als
kranführer in der mine in jeffrey
trainiert 114 football clubs in jungen
welt - dort zur ablage ist spielen die
vier clubs in eine eigene liga genannt
die letzten minuten jedes viertel sind
entscheiden wenn im tempo aus dem spiel
und holen treffer wir müssen gewinnen
hart arbeiten viel rennen wieder mal
sind viel später ins augen schicht von
rimini geteilt wurde
steam von o bis o
[Applaus]
angst vor der kamera ich bin der falsche
wenn nicht für österreich sprechen
[Gelächter]
arbeiten arbeiten für die letzten acht
jahre
also das heißt in der mine arbeitet hier
als sprengmeister sprengmeister okay
spannend war schon eine weile nicht mehr
deutschen ich komisch mit meinen eltern
ja ist das funktioniert super man nicht
so wenn ich jetzt wenn ich überrascht
werden muss
[Musik]
und seit acht jahren lebt zehn jungen
und dann arbeitest du zwei wochen und
gefühl nach hause freien fly out
bedeutet dass die arbeiter nicht in
human or und sonnen für die geschichte
erwarten sie schaffen der zwei wochen
durch und fliegen wir sind das leben
hier jungen ja ich meine du lebst ja
trotzdem immer immerhin würde ich mal
sagen zwei drittel des jahres den jungen
das kämpfen also wir sind nicht leben
nicht nur arbeit für 13 stunden am tag
bekommt nach hause was du jetzt ins bett
musste man kann nicht begleitet du
kommst doch was leisten so verdienst und
kannst ja auch was ich bin
wenn man alleine damit zwei jahren ist
ein motorrad hat ein haus konsum luxus
leisten immer einfach
er muss da ist man arbeitet für 14 tage
nämlich drei viertel des jahres abo was
ihr sozialleben kommt auch eine
verständigung ist stelle ich mir sehr
schwierig vor meine ist kaputt gegangen
ja also ich bin wenn ich irgendwann habe
ich eine freundin gehabt aber einfach
dass das was ich tue ist nicht einfach
aber es hat gut um schlechte positive
sozial habe von jungen ist bescheiden
mit trifft im pop oder win football fans
von the saints and next für jedes team
verliert hoch will wenig später sind
müsste trainer persönlich springen also
optimal
ein spieler zu wenig viel aufregung ein
verletzter spieler so schlecht war es
nicht angesichts der umstände so ist es
bei uns die jungs machen flying j
die arbeit ist wichtiger als der sport
das ist schwierig und wie bist du mit
deiner leistung zufrieden
ich bin einfach zu alt ich bin 50
verdammt ich sollte das nicht mehr tun
das ist das für einen 17-jährigen in
wirklich fertig aber trotzdem
gratulationen und vielen dank jetzt gibt
es das obligate bier und einen abrieb
regierung
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen verlor nicht wieder
statt wenn wir nach neun spielen
ich möchte unbedingt zu bitten und
verbiegen ein ort ganze nation vor
[Musik]
mit nur drei schritten und ist ein
spezielles steht ein waren text zu
bitten um verständnis
eine 60er jahre hat mir die stadt
geschlossen und damit dem vorstand
eigentlich nichts hören
ein wunder ist natürlich weg ich begebe
mich erst mal aufarbeiten
in letztes volk suche die gäste stand
und traf zur minenbranche keiner war
nicht im entferntesten aktie
[Musik]
meeresbiologie danny webb nimmt mich ins
netz und zeigt die riesige bereit
und ich spüre flüchtlinge aus
afghanistan
[Musik]
spannende begegnungen auf abenteuerliche
art wagen 12 380 kilometer durch
ausstrahlen
[Musik]
12 1378 km australien mit globetrotter
dem spezialist für massgeschneiderte
reisewelt mit globetrotter